toi aussi tu as des crottes au coin des
yeux quand tu te réveilles dis pas non
céit pas une question en fait toi aussi
tu te demandes et c'est quoi en vrai les
cacas d'œil benah je vais t'expliquer ça
nos yeux ils ont une fonction
autonettoyante comme nos organes
génitaux et dans nos yeux il y a plein
de trucs à nettoyer comme nos organes
génitaux il y a nos cellules mortes qui
se renouvellent sans arrêt il y a une
espèce de liquide gras qui lubrifie nos
yeux pour pas qu'il se dessèche oui nos
yeux ils sont aussi autolubrifiants
comme nos organes génitaux et puis il y
a tout ce qui vient de l'extérieur des
bactéries des poussières et cetera
pendant la journée tout ça c'est dilué
dans nos larmes et c'est évacué quand on
Cline des yeux mais la nuit on Cline pas
des yeux vu qu'ils sont fermés donc ça
s'évacue pas ça stagne ça sèche et le
lendemain matin caca d'œil d'ailleurs
leur vrai nom c'est la châsie et c'est
l'anagramme de vous voyez quoi et en
vrai c'est normal parce que c'est dérivé
d'un mot latin qui veut dire défqué la
boucle est boucl